Turning on a roll board
for the first time after
6 or 8 months of hard work
and see it working properly;
it's the best feeling in the world.
2 years ago with a friend,
we were the first Argentians
to win an international
robotics competition.
I felt I needed to spread the word
and help get more and more people
into robotics.
I started travelling the country,
teaching robotics,
so the kids can get
great tools for the future.
I see them working with robot,
and they feel they are just playing,
but they are learning how
to be incredibly proficient.
They feel, "I am too young to do
these kinds of things",
but they are not.
So when you get that idea,
inside their heads,
they are unstoppable.
But one of my goals is to create
a generation of great robotics developers,
and great competitors,
that will change the world.
Mateo is also the found of ¡Hablalo!
an app to help deaf and mute people communicate more easily.
Mateo Salvatto.
Robotics champion.
App maker.
Celebrating app makers worldwide
Share your #IMakeApps story